Ever wonder what it takes to be a beauty queen?
Hi, I'm Justin Popovics, a pageant fitness trainer...
...and official fitness trainer for Miss New York, New Hampshire and Florida USA.
Here are some tips and tricks of the trade that you can take along with you in your quest for the crown.
In a beauty pageant, introductions are critical.
It gives you the opportunity to tell the judges who you are, where you're from, and what your goal is...
...which ultimately is the crown.
Today, I'm gonna teach you how to do your own pageant intro.
Think about who you are and where you're from...
...and some of the landmarks in your state.
Then put them together in a nice sound bite that's fun and catchy.
For example:...
"From the Statue of Liberty to Lake Ontario, I'm proud to represent the Empire State of New York."
"From Manhattan, I'm Justin Popovics."
Let's do that one more time, but a little more slowly.
"From the Statue of Liberty to Lake Ontario, I'm proud to represent the Empire State of New York."
"From Manhattan, I'm Justin Popovics."